hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the uh 1858
second match between these two gentlemen
paul charles morphy and otto anderson
after the first series match now we have
this one that's basically taking place
while the camera the photographers are
getting ready to take the photo of the
two gentlemen and a lot of you have sent
me this um i think it's from ed winter's
chess history website so here it is uh
these are uh the gentleman anderson and
morphy over the board playing uh
overlooking the board are riviere and
the mac and not max landry we are in the
saint amand uh and it's uh well it's not
very detailed but you you it's uh
the best we have so let's just enjoy
that for a second before we return to
this well beautiful third game of the
second match
so there you have it hope you guys
enjoyed that now let's check it out
we're gonna have a repetition of the
first game and then at some point
anderson will deviate uh well in hopes
of improving his uh result from game one
uh so uh
morphe with the white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 f4 morphe goes for the
king's gambit e captures on f4 knight to
f3 and g5 so everything like in game one
bishop the c4 and bishop the g7 if you
haven't checked out the video from game
one of this match you do check it out as
we've discussed uh all of the moves that
uh you're seeing here in length uh we
have castles by morphe and now d6 we
have c3 morphe now ready to grab the
full center here with d4 and knight to
c6 we have queen to b3 threatening to
capture on f7 queen to e7 anderson
defense and now d4 and here we had this
position in game one of the match where
anderson replied with knight to f6 and
we said that it was a pretty dangerous
line allowing the knight captures on g5
like this and we discussed that uh
instead of this a move like h6 goes uh
well really goes a long way and there's
no way for white to really do anything
here black's position is perfectly fine
your next moves are knight of six
castles and you know you just continue
playing the game so for some reason
anderson did not enjoy this anderson did
not enjoy defending he did not enjoy uh
you know grabbing pawns he he wanted to
develop and he wanted to attack problem
is that morphe was just uh faster in
doing those things and even if you even
if white wanted to bust open with with a
move like g3 i'm just going to show a
fun line it's perfectly fine to capture
here there's no way to take advantage of
everything uh honing in on that f7 pawn
even if knight captures on g5h captures
and bishop captures an f7 check we can
play king 28 and now if white wants to
win back the piece then it's a problem g
captures on h2 with check and now if
king h1 queen captures on e4 is a very
quick check made rook f3 queen captures
on f3 and if not if you want to play
something else like king the g2 that
doesn't really matter still a queen uh
will go to e4 with czech king g3 rook h3
check and that's uh just it king f2 rook
f3 check and you're getting checkmated
king g2 we need to check and now well it
doesn't really matter what you're
playing you're getting checkmated so
after h6 black's position is perfectly
fine here but the the theory was not all
that developed and then not so much
theory but the defending in chess wasn't
uh
uh
that wasn't uh the point of the game and
uh the problem is morphe just defended
too well when he had to so here anderson
tries a6 in this position saying okay i
didn't play knight to f6 there's really
no way for white to take advantage of
this position but there is one way so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this absolutely best move
for morphe while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on again going for
the same move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's knight
captures and g5 uh this time it works uh
because there's bishop captures on f4 on
the next move if you guys are wondering
so queen captures was played with bishop
captures on f7 with check and now if
king to f8 it doesn't really help uh
we're not going to capture the the
knight here we're just going to play
bishop captures on f4 and now only after
the queen moves we're going to capture
the knight and there's no way for black
to answer this you can't capture with
the rook because all of the nasty
discoveries then become possible and of
course the king cannot capture because
the queen is defending the bishop so
here after bishop captures an f7 morph
he played king sorry anderson played
king to d8 and now bishop captures on f4
queen to e7 and now morphy wins back his
piece bishop captures and g8 and now
anderson has to find uh
well a reasonable way of how to continue
the game and he plays bishop to g4
nothing extreme like bishop to h3 like
in the previous game uh but okay uh he's
asking maybe morphy is interested in the
b7 pawn but that makes little sense if
you capture here then the rook will
simply move attack the queen and once
queen captures on c6 we're going to play
real captures on g8 and morphe for the
price of one pawn basically activated
both of anderson's rooks so that's not
the way you play chess so morphe
continues by developing knights to d2
and now king to d7 the king will now
also help out with the defense of the
knight if this ever happens although
very unlikely and the rooks are now
connected threatening to pick up the
bishop here so bishop back to d5 by
morphe and now knight to d8
defending the the b7 pawn once but
morphy now even captures the pawn
there's no there's no reason to do this
you could also play just e5 you could go
knight to c for a lot of candidate moves
here but morphy says this is uh just
sufficient bishop captures and b7 point
is that if rook b8 queen a4 check gets
the queen out of the out of harm's way
so knight captures on b7 we have queen
capture sun b7 and now anderson played
a5 uh saying that all right now i'm
gonna bring my rooks into the attack and
my king is perfectly safe here but that
could not be further from the truth so
feel free to pause the video for the
second time here and win the game for
morphe while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding uh well uh
bishop g5 is fine knight to c4 is final
of these moves are fine but the
absolutely crushing move and the one
that morphe played is bishop captures on
d6 and the point of it is of course
removing the queen from the defense of
the f7 square and now there's it really
doesn't matter what you play queen
captures and c7 is a thread bishop
capture series a threat so you have to
play something uh here if you capture
right away then morphy's idea of course
is rook to f7 check and there's no good
way of uh
replying here we're going to capture the
bishop and now
whatever you play let's say the rook is
hanging here rook to d8 now we simply
play knight to c4 attack the queen and
after the queen moves now we play queen
captures on c7 so the queen moved here
to kind of defend the bishop but it
really doesn't help if rook to d7 we can
even trade here captures captures and
queen e5 check picks up the other rook
and that's it so anderson said all right
obviously the bishop
cannot be captured i'm gonna give up my
bishop instead because you will win it
uh either way we have c characters on d4
and now queen captures on d6 but now
it's pretty much the same thing morphy
simply played rook to f7 check and he
was in this position uh on move 19 again
morphe wins uh in 19 moves that out of
anderson resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here whatever
you play let's say bring the king here
if you go to d8 or e8 you just lose the
real quick check so let's say king e6 uh
runs into the beautiful queen b3 check
and the rook is preventing the king from
escaping the queen defends the rook uh
and this is uh well this is pretty
awesome i might even use this for a
thumbnail uh but yeah you'd have to
block with the queen and then just queen
captures and d5 is checkmate so that's
why anderson resigned after this rook to
f7 check and yet another victory for
paul charles morphy in their second
match in paris in 1858 so it's three to
zero for morphe uh we'll see if it will
be six to zero or will maybe anderson
have something else to say about this
but like i said uh the problem is not
with anderson's choice of openings or or
with his ideas it's just that in this
position he's refusing to play h6 after
h6 morphe would
definitely struggle with with what to
play here it's okay it's an ugly move to
play but once you play it there's really
no easy way for for white to break
through maybe he will you know stumble
upon this maybe not we'll see what
happens next in the saga so there you
have it hope you guys enjoyed it game
three of the second match uh i would
like to thank harry walk peter shugart
michael keane uh online by moore and
dimitra angelo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day